investigators in you know and these your
are working to find the organizers of an
attack that killed four American
soldiers deborah potter is at night new
jars capital neon naye one issue there
is why the army unit was operating in a
region beyond the government's control
Deborah good morning good morning we
spoke to a Nigerian soldier who is
stationed at the base nearest to the
site of the ambush he claims he
personally knew the four Americans who
were killed another trained him in
counterterrorism tactics he recalls
cracking military jokes with him despite
the language barrier now he believes
that ambush troops were deliberately
delayed in the village of Tonga Tonga
which is in a region known as syllabary
the government has absolutely no control
there and is investigating the suspicion
that some of the villagers might have
been complicit in this attack this is
one of the most remote and chaotic war
zones in the world they are more than a
dozen extremist groups operating along
the border between Mali anglish a
particular attack was coordinated by
Isis than the greater Sahel and is led
by Adnan Abu Walid al Sahara we mean and
it's been actively recruiting in that
region so the presence of American
troops they would have drawn immediate
attention and that begs the question why
they went into such a dangerous location
with very little backup
Nora very good question Debora patta and
me Jer thank you